oh okay he's gonna die right getting
surrounded not looking wait what's that
in the sky oh
dragon fire is this the blood worm
carraxis
did they not expect a second dragon
you always got to expect a second dragon
oh
i want to talk about this more later oh
okay
beautiful work beautiful work you're
smart dracar is indeed
dracaris indeed
he likes the shoulder he likes the moves
yeah
where's where's that
where's that deformed weirdo give me the
weirdo i want the weirdo
welcome back to new rock stars the crab
feeder is now crab food rhaenyra has a
new baby brother with another brother or
sister on the way and a new dragon rider
has entered the chat yes this is big
question presents talking dragons our
weekly fantasy after show look at that
graphic oh my gosh it's so good so fiery
i'm brandenburg uh and with me today we
got a special guest on the show it's
zach huddleston yes i came uh to engage
you in a dwarven endurance test oh okay
and that dwarven endurance test is doing
an episode of talking dragons that's
right we're we're either going to finish
the episode or give up
i don't know what's going to happen uh
as always here on talking dragon talking
dragons we're keeping things future
spoiler free as possible in regards to
the events of the book okay we can talk
about things that happened in the past
we could talk about things that happen
on game of thrones but anything that's
going to happen in the book uh
we won't try and spoil it we're trying
to keep it tv show canon yes so if there
are differences between the books we
will be ignoring the book differences
and trying to focus on the show also for
the first time i'm talking dragons we
will be mentioning rings of power brings
the power okay
it costs a lot of money and we're gonna
talk about it yes yes your your your
amazon prime orders have funded this
show it is here we're gonna talk about
it this show is the reason those
warehouse workers can't get health
insurance
uh the alexa is listening to us as we
say these things uh but let's kick off
talking dragons uh by discussing episode
three of house of the dragon titled
second of his name oh it's been three
whole years uh that have gone by since
the last time we looked in on westeros
viserys and allison are married and
their union has already produced a son
oh problem solved
and it's little aegon's second name day
that's what they call a birthday in
westeros the war against the triarchy
wages on and the step stones but who
wants to hear about that right now we've
got a lot of feasting yes it was a good
food episode
or maybe a bad food episode depending on
your opinions but in honor of little
aegon's uh second name day by the way i
did like there's a little variation in
the show but for the most part they're
calling him aegon yeah as in egg on your
face big disgrace
okay um uh in honor of that second name
day uh they're holding a royal hunt now
royal hunts uh in the history of uh
um
game of thrones not always a good thing
for kings and i think this one does not
necessarily end well for the king robert
baratheon uh basically died as a result
of his big royal hunt uh but they're
bringing in bannermen from all across
the land including some potential
partners for the still unbetrothed
renera uh otter's older brother lord
hobert hightower is here and boy he is
um hey just straight up calling second
of his name okay basically we're in
front of the current king you only you
only become the second of your name once
you are king yeah so he's basically
saying like hey this little kid's gonna
be the king someday um he's also
leaning into his brother otto to push
viserys right to announce aegon as his
heir um
lots of people getting pulled in
multiple directions by a lot of
whisperers in their in their ear for
sure that's true uh rhaenyra is still
clearly miffed about the union of her
best friend and her father but is also
rightfully concerned about her supposed
role as heir as as you pointed out it's
clear that many of the lords are eager
to move little aegon into the role of
prince of dragonstone and eventually
take the throne because they want to see
the men stay in power because it's
pretty good if you're a lord in westeros
yeah especially a first son yeah not to
be confused with a second not the second
time uh and of course rhaenyra and her
relationship with alison is icy the last
we saw of them she's kind of given her
the death stare after realizing she's
been macking on her dad and is moving in
to become her new stepmom also alexander
has been super busy she's pregnant she's
already got one kid right not a lot of
progress from rainier in the last three
years now she's still kind of hanging
out under the trees she's reading her
body she's reading music we can assume
she did some dragon training in the
interim but she's not finding uh lovers
okay she's not she's not politicking to
gain power or sway uh she's probably
been moping it's been a very hot topic
three years for ramirez i think uh been
very emo um but uh you know allison
still trying to mend fences still wants
to be friends still wants to be good uh
stepmother um and uh and she's also like
she's getting pushed by her father otto
of course to be politicking on behalf of
her son uh viserys is torn right she's
still kind of like that
that um uh therapist
you know she's helping him with this
trauma what happened with what happened
with his first wife and
the fact that his body parts are falling
off oh we're gonna we're gonna talk
about that hey fitting that episode
three and that's the same number of
fingers that viserys has on one hand
okay while allison is keeping an eye
profile uh right like she's she is
starting to play the game she's clearly
learned the lessons from her father who
is a master kind of uh game player
politicker uh
littlefinger adjace um she convinces
rainier to come along on the hunt
despite her being very mopey and emo and
not wanting to go she kind of talks
viserys into helping damon right at the
end of the episode into finally sending
support to damon and corliss's war
against the crab feeder so she in her
own kind of a subtle way she's pulling
some strength yeah she's she's not as
like forceful as other ones she's very
good at kind of like getting her way
with just little looks and little nods
and little little conversations so we're
at the royal hunt uh and there's news of
a fabled white heart which is like a big
white deer which would be a powerful
royal omen on aegon's b day but the
other big news is who ramirez might be
married to eventually jason lannister
ever heard of that name he shoots his
shot and he misses but he has the king's
blessing but she's not into it clearly
the honey wine doesn't taste so great uh
lord lionel strong suggests the sea
snake's son leynor veleron as a
potential match and otto hightower goes
for the wild card suggestion uh to marry
off uh rhaenyra to aegon uh her little
brother and gets laughed gets laughed
he gets laughed after the suggestion i
mean this is not out of the realm of
targaryens to marry their siblings but
this is something that like the church
does not like uh and they're never for
this this kind of behavior because it
goes against the what what the the royal
church has to say both the incest and
the wild age difference not out of
keeping with uh general game of thrones
but specifically
with targaryen heritage there yeah right
uh viserious uh gets
real snookered real wasted at his party
hey it's his party he can drink if he
wants i mean we were talking about the
the chalice on this man okay
he is the lord of the seven kingdoms
okay so of course he's gonna have a good
cup but he is he's pounding that dornish
wine or wherever that line's from um and
you know we were talking a little bit
about
this is i think viserys is an effectual
leader right he's not a man of action
he's kind of gets torn he's like back
and forth uh but it's clear it's like
he's weighed down by the burden of being
a ruler i don't think he was necessarily
built for this right he's not a
hyper-confident guy uh probably in good
ways a lot of the time because he's not
rushing his kingdom into battle and war
a lot right he's hesitant he he's
reigning over peace and he wants to
maintain that peace if at all possible
but also it's clearly like eating him
from the inside or physically from the
outside with his maladies right and he's
clearly mentally starting to deteriorate
right even pointed out um it looks like
they gave him a different wig this
episode airlines a little further and
there's a little less volume in that
targaryen
white mane
he's getting older and he's clearly like
falling apart and yeah he's a guy who
wasn't
it wasn't like he was prepped to be king
from birth
because his his father was like fourth
of jaharis's kids so he was not like in
the line right from the jump it was very
later on in his life that it was like oh
you might get to be king uh and that
kind of
he he he doesn't want to be king he
doesn't want to go to war he doesn't
want to have these fights he just wants
to work on his model in his room alone
yes and like
he clearly that that was like never more
apparent than during that drunken scene
and during his conflicts with rhaenyra
where i love he has this line right even
i am not above the the customs of the
land or whatever right which is
basically him saying hey i was forced to
have to i'm the king and i have to do
this yeah and you're going to be forced
to do that he wasn't happy to do all of
this politicking and marrying uh for
yeah sick of all this
all
advantage
that's a good take thank you um
uh and so he also has this great speech
in front of this big bonfire at the hunt
where he's telling um allison that he's
he's a dreamer not a dragon big deal
right which is a big deal especially for
targaryens we're known it's house of the
dragons the name of this show and when
you straight up call yourself not a
dragon rider i don't think that bodes
well for your future on this show right
right
but he's a dreamer which throughout game
of thrones we've seen a lot of
especially targaryens right dreaming
having visions
of of their destiny the prince who was
promised danis the dreamer was a very
important targaryen because she was the
one that was like yo we gotta get out of
valeria cause it's gonna go bad uh and
she basically saved the targaryen line
by getting them out of there so being a
dreamer while being a dragon rider is a
big deal and it's part of being a
targaryen if you are a good dreamer and
your dreams are true and they're right
and your visions are correct they can
save them and like viserys you know he
very much believes the song of ice and
fire he's very paranoid about that he's
always got his dagger in every scene you
see it it's there he's ready for this
winter to come uh so i think him saying
like hey i'm a dreamer
it's it's him saying maybe i'm not a
great king i'm not a dragon writer but
my dreams are important yes and we need
to make sure that they're correct well
we know that dagger from the preview for
next episode is going to have an
important role in the next episode of
this series and like you pointed out in
that speech right as he's talking about
this dream he had of seeing his son on
the iron throne right there's this
moment of uncertainty where he's like
i'm not sure and is he not sure if it's
a son on the iron throne is he not sure
uh if it's even his progeny that's on
the iron throne right like there's a lot
of ambiguity these dreams as we saw like
throughout game of thrones right azura
high and prince was promised and like oh
it could have been him and like oh
actually no it was stannis was wrong the
whole time he shouldn't have killed his
daughter all this crazy stuff right
the vision can be real but your
interpretation of the vision is not
necessarily accurate and it feels like
that's where he's being torn yeah he's
not sure what to believe yeah yeah
uh
so he's he's waiting around for them to
catch this like white stag because
unlike baratheon who goes out and does
all the hunting himself and it winds up
getting him killed viserys sits back and
lets them corner the stag and he'll show
up when it's time to do the stabbing uh
he they do corner the stag but it's not
the fabled white one that we'd heard so
much about uh and so again if you look
at like visions and dreams and what they
mean like him seeing this brown stag uh
does it mean that his son because it is
his son's birthday uh he shouldn't be
the king like he's not destined to be
the king is that what this means he
almost seems kind of relieved to see
that it's not a white stag and it's just
a brown one and he's like he's also
pretty hungover so i don't know yeah
how he's feeling that day uh i thought
your boy was a white heart turned out it
was a brown snake turns out it was a
bronze tag uh meanwhile rhaenyra she
dips out from most of the party and
hangs out in the woods with sir kristen
cole hello this guy is a troublemaker uh
they get attacked by a boar and play a
little boar on the floor uh but cole
manages to stab it and the rhaenyra
straight up murders that board she goes
hardcore on it uh drenched in blood
rainier comes back uh heads back to camp
and comes across the white heart on
their way but she decides to let it be
so she sees the white heart is this part
of a prophecy is she destined to take
the throne and she but she doesn't go
after it and does that mean she doesn't
want the throne anymore is that her
saying like i'm not interested or did
she get what she needed just by seeing
it that's the omen that she needs like
she shows that she's willing to kill
she'll kill the boar but only when she
needs to right she's not gonna go out of
her way to kill well this like white
house also is it a metaphor she's
actually not willing to do whatever it
takes to secure her lineage she's not
willing to to marry in a certain way
that would guarantee she gets the throne
right she could have now also i just
want to real quick question the
practicality
there's this giant
white white uh deer-like creature right
maybe 50 yards away from them sir
christian cole pulls out a sword right
my dude are you gonna throw that sword
at that thing how are you gonna you're
on foot
he's pretty fast get out of here i saw
him at the combat i had no you see him
at the we they cut it out of the episode
but at the kingsguard combines this guy
his 40 was insane in in armor yeah yeah
in armor
you got to run in the armor i think what
that's dad could have also charged you
know you got to be ready to defend it's
true maybe he's with he's with the air
he's got to be maybe there's a certain
stag what would a stag call sound like
to attract a stag if you want to attract
the white heart you got to give it a
little
[Applause]
that's a white heart call damn dude i
just got hard
white hard
so after the hunt uh is all said and
done rhaenyra and viserys have it out
again they have a little tiff uh and
viserys appears to be willing to let
rhaenyra choose who she wants to wed
even though she does not seem keen on
getting married and pumping out babies
uh he says you know you can get married
for love because he reveals that he
actually really loved emma and was like
very happy to marry her uh and it's
clear that he does feel bad about
killing her he does feel a lot of
remorse for that um and it just hurt
dying in general yeah well and he's
basically saying hey you can have both
yeah
there's a dozen there's a dozen dudes
out here that want to marry you you must
have some a connection with at least one
of them i found mine at least try to
find yours don't be pushing back just
against the concept of marion exactly
and most important this conversation he
assures her that he's not trying to
remove her as heir yeah this is yet
again him saying like look i chose you
and you're gonna do it i don't know if
this hunt has kind of showed him with
his visions and not seeing the white
white heart i feel like yeah maybe i
should let my daughter keep this for now
he's torn throughout the episode right
anybody that that questions him having
renera as his heir he pushes back
immediately
the hightower is right he he's not
publicly second guessing himself though
we know internally he is a little torn
yeah right that's his own little mini
rebellion it's like everyone is on
everyone on his council and otto
hightower they're all like you have to
do these things as king like you have to
get married again right yeah and here's
who you should marry and his response to
that is like i'll get married again but
i'm marrying allison the one that most
of you told me not to marry yeah or
didn't suggest for me to marry so it's
like he's willing to do the things but
he he's going to have his own little
rebellion inside so like yes you have to
name an heir but i'm going to name my
daughter even though you all hate that
idea well also maybe speaks to maybe not
the best decision maker yeah maybe i'm
not a great kid the family they're not
all winners that's right hey uh now
finally our where we end the episode we
head to the step zones um where the
triarchy
has really figured out a nice counter
punch to dragons and that's
caves caves babies who knew that the
achilles heel of giant fire-breathing
dragons is just to chill out in caves
was this is this the vietnam of westeros
that's right that they dug into the
tunnels they can't get them out uh and
they're just like you know what
it's a tie yeah i mean literally because
right like we you could drive napalm all
day yeah but hey man we're in foxholes
okay um and so right we're at this uh
this breaking point the valerian forces
are uh mutiny they're always like ships
they're out almost out of ships they're
not going to get reinforcements at times
uh the two uh corliss and his brother
are at each other right the lord of
complaints
and just when things are at their
breaking point damon rides in uh
at the same time that a messenger from
the king shows up he's like hey the king
says i'm gonna help now normally what's
that phrase what do you not want to do
to the messenger you don't want to kill
the messenger or yeah at least not beat
him with your hand well and we don't
know we didn't check the vitals on that
messenger we assume he survives he limps
back uh to king's landing i bet the
whole time they were heading to the step
zones he's like the king gave me the
message guys
i'm giving it to david all right i'm the
big dog here i get the nice cot as we're
traveling to the step stones he's
walking up this is my big boat oh yeah
i'm giving the letter i bet this is a
good letter he's gonna be so happy
together
of all the helmets to get beaten with
that is not enough that's how much it
would have been with this doesn't have a
nice smooth helmet he was avoiding the
feather side too because he doesn't want
to get the feather oh there was some
there was some protrusions there so he
pisses him off i want to point out right
we were talking about this before
neither damon nor the crab feeder speak
a single line of dialogue that's the
entire episode
we never got to hear the crab feeder
speak no ever no i had a french accent
i'm only going to assume um but we get
that great long close-up shot of damon
as he processes this news right he's
furious at his brother he wanted this
now you and i are on different pages
here right i think he wanted to come up
here he thought this was uh
uh iraq war uh 2001. he was going to
sweep in get a quick w
get a quick win to prove to the entire
kingdom hey i deserve to be king i'm a
man of action i can win this it's been
three long years they can't win and in
fact it seems like they're losing
um and so he's already on the brink and
then now he has to get saved by his
ineffectual brother right that snaps him
so he beats the messenger and they
formulate this new plan now you think
it's slightly different what leads into
the damon's motivations that lead to the
next i think he was kind of slow playing
the whole thing i think damon was fine
to have this kind of long drawn-out
battle where he gets to fly around he
gets to kill some people every day yeah
he's probably frustrated that he's not
winning but he's also
much like him stealing the dragon egg
and saying like i'm getting married
tomorrow
he he wants his brother's attention he
wants his brother to show up and come
down there and say like just be aware of
what he's doing and like face him
come face to face with him and he gets a
letter from it from his brother saying
like hey i'm sending some ships and i'm
praying for you and i hope you don't die
he's like screw this i'm tired of this
and like i think he he it is a little
bit of a suicide mission like maybe he's
willing to die he also knows he's not
going to die he's damon targaryen he's
not afraid of death it's episode three
yeah uh
so so he's willing to go on this like
suicide mission on bloodstone uh he's
the human being yeah as they say right
he's like he wants to get this done
before the ship show up because he's
like if if viserys isn't coming then
this is over and i'm gonna end it yeah
because i don't want this to be a
viserys win right i want this to be a
damon win right right right so we've got
to go now and he's humbled by this
consistent losses of three years so he's
got to get off the dragon yeah this is
not damon and caraxies this is just
damon davis they say he's the only one
that is like bold enough to go down
there and do this yeah and the i think
the only one that they're willing to
give up their safety for is i think in
their mind like the crab feeder is like
well if we can get damon that takes a
dragon rider off the field and like he's
our biggest problem right now yeah and
i'm willing to risk a few hundred of my
men yeah they will be suckered in to go
fight him also i do love still very
targaryen they're like waving a false
white flag that's right you know i mean
you can argue about the rules of war
because i don't think the crab feeder is
following the rules of war no i don't
think the geneva the geneva convention
does not uh cover feeding your enemies
to crustaceans right i don't think but
it should it should add it up um yeah
and so we get this awesome sequence
where he's go in uh as you say um leroy
jenkins oh leroy on the um crab feeders
army just slicing and dyson one man
right dodging arrows got a little plot
armor but he takes a couple he takes a
couple of couple hits okay and just when
you just when he's surrounded we were
reacting to the scene at the beginning
of this episode boom we get um we got
some dragon fire and that's not caraxies
sea smoke and that is lanor valerian
riding him uh now we knew the valerians
right there from a similar lineage to
targaryens we knew they were also a
dragon rider well they're not the
valerians are not dragon riders but
because coral is married he's half
targaryen he's laynor's half targaryen
so he's got that that dragon rider blood
inside of him great yeah thank you for
clearing that up uh and so he swoops in
we didn't know right this is also we
were mentioning before this is an actor
time jump the last we saw elaine nor he
was played by a much younger tinier
actor at the
the the tournament yes uh uh celebrating
the
with his white birth of another yeah and
with his uh tiny sister who his parents
were trying to marry off to a young ass
man um but clearly the last three years
have uh included puberty yeah and some
dragon training for laynor because he
comes through in the clutch he zaps
those crab feeder archers uh allowing uh
the valerian forces to swoop in defeat
the crab feeder he's having a good old
time he's basically like now this is
dragon riding
and uh you know
uh the crab feeder half the man he used
to be you know what i mean uh paul went
out for the crab feeder we hardly knew
you that actor does not get residuals
because he didn't speak any lines i
though i did love i love i loved his
choice of like he kind of moves like a
crab his little like ticks yes i love
that also i mean and he was all he knew
something was up he was watching the
skies constantly because uh you know
they mentioned earlier in the episode
like oh we're using our dragons they
kind of teased that there were multiple
dragons involved in this whole scenario
but we didn't know this uh but he he
knew something was up he was always on
the watch but
in the end well and i wonder if there's
something to to karaxis is dark red
during a day battle he's going to stand
out in the sky wow sea smoke is uh you
know a lighter he's kind of gray
sizes he's small maybe he was easier to
sneak in rather than big ass uh blood
worm there um uh but either way right
damon emerges victorious and just like
his niece
ends the episode with that beautiful
white hair soaked in blood right nice
parallel and like again this show is
taking place after a long period of
peace right so like most of these
characters right that's why kristen cole
becomes uh uh gets his promotion right
because he's one of the few people in
this entire show that has seen battle
and now rhaenyra
and damon have seen their own version of
battle have come out of it hardened
maybe more confident maybe ready to
attack the rest of this season uh that's
right and we're
very excited to attack the rest of this
episode but first be sure to check out
newrockstarsmerch.com where you can grab
our newest latest obsession shirt ashton
ruin inspired by all the fire and blood
action on house of the dragon now this
is a limited edition shirt and it will
be gone faster than becerris's digits so
be sure to grab yours today at
newrockstarsmerch.com
and when you grab this latest obsession
shirt you unlock the opportunity to get
a custom shout out that will appear
right here on talking dragons and we
might even read them live on the air
just like these uh jessica lee jones
daniel is the true heir to the throne
suck it can we say suck it suck it we
can say that's from danny d nice one
damn
darth dr
drakonis yeah dr conus is on the rise
baby uh that's from sean g nice uh so
yeah be sure to check out
newrockstarsmerch.com and grab that and
you know the latest obsession shirts as
brandon said they're always limited
edition i'm actually wearing the limited
edition latest obsession shirt from the
batman uh and they release cool ones all
the time there's a great one out right
now also for she-hulk there'll be a cool
one coming out soon for andor um we also
want to give a quick shout out to our
friends over at secret lab they make a
fancy funky gaming and desk office
chairs very nice quality yeah
comfortable and they did us a solid um i
don't know if we have do we have the
camera angle to be able to show this we
might need to pull it on the camera um
but they sent us some really cool uh
house of the dragon and game of thrones
uh
gaming chairs and like they not only
have the kind of cool fun you get your
stark emblem or your lannister emblem or
your game of thrones
but like great detail we were pointing
out like the house of the dragon one has
this kind of like dragon scale pattern
on it beautiful uh different types of
fabrics like the little dragon scale
patterns little dragons hidden on it
uh you can get one and just check out
their entire line over at
secretlab.com
game of thrones again that's secret lab
dot co slash game of thrones thank you
to secret lab for sending us those cool
chairs um so as we were saying like we
were all surprised to see another dragon
take to the skies this episode along
with leonard valerian on his back uh
confirming that this son of rainis and
corliss valerian is a dragon rider but
did it really take three years of
fighting to come up with this like great
plan that would end it immediately it
all leads us to our big question this
week
who is sea smoke and why wasn't he used
sooner uh
uh it is very interesting i assumed like
that because there's been kind of three
years going on we just haven't seen them
you you know they've been using sea
smoke because this clearly wasn't
leonard's like first dragon ride i mean
he's been on a dragon before he knew
what he was doing uh so i i took it to
be that like it took them three years to
kind of get the triarchy cornered on
this one little island which i believe
they called bloodstone
uh and that's where they're like they're
holding siege right they're kind of
blockaded they're surrounded they're
stuck in there but they can't kill off
all these people as we saw at the
beginning of the episode right the
dragon can come down and then blow a
little fire into the cave but it's not
doing much and he's just open season for
yeah uh for whoever's on the dragon's
back down there i did love that guy
the guy
my princess here to save me they've been
getting this gosh maybe one of the
funniest moments uh in all of the game
of thrones to date but very very good uh
well and one thing i think is hinted at
in this sequence right is
maybe
sea swope c smoke and leonard was being
held back by
clearly damon was running the ship yeah
yeah damon on
caraxies right and so really it again
took him
to the the brink of failure before he
realized his strategy of just going in
there guns ablaze in on his dragon was
not working he had to be humbled he had
to literally humble himself down to
ground level right with just one man one
plan and a sword right uh and it was
only then right that c smoke and lanor
were able to be truly helpful not as
dragon number two but really as the lead
dragon with with your uh distant cousin
down there on the ground yeah um i like
that and you had pointed out because
leonard is older in the books yes right
he would have been more experienced
maybe they would have shown him more
actively involved in the battle up until
that point but because we're assuming
maybe this also is kind of his first big
move maybe you've been participating but
they weren't as confident in both this
pretty young
kid he's a younger guy in the in the
show and it's a young dragon yeah right
yeah sea smoke it was is leonard's
dragon he was bonded with it as a baby
like you know how they talk about they
want to put the egg with the kid so
that's his dragon uh yeah in the books
he's a little older he was involved in
like the great council and all that
stuff but
for the purposes of the show he's
younger i think it's smart because they
he's clearly like uh an option for a
rhaenyra you know more product sense
yeah uh and as uh lord strong loves to
point out
to viserys like i keep telling you you
need to join forces with uh house
valeron because like you two together
these two houses tied together through
marriage would be so incredibly powerful
it would put to bed a lot of the the
gust between you yeah because lord
corliss the sea snake he's no longer the
master of ships right in the last
episode he basically was like i quit uh
and that's why there's a lannister now
who's like the head of ships who was the
who was the twin of jason who was like
basically being like we need to go deal
with the stepstones uh and viserys is
like i don't give a crap about those
episodes i don't care it's my brother
all right so yeah it was cool to see
this like plan come and like work uh but
yeah it does see it it does kind of feel
like
they were slow playing it for the
purposes of the story you know we don't
we don't see much of it now in the books
again this is just like a page in the
book right it's basically like it just
mentions offhandedly that damon kills
the crab feeder cuts off his head with
dark sister uh i love that they go for
the cuts off his half of his body almost
making him look like a crab which i i
loved like all the little things just
torso and arms just torso arms and guts
baby kind of cracked them open like a
soft shell
but i i did i did really like seeing
that i i think you got to know too when
when damon's on your island and he's
waving the white flag be suspicious but
also when he's like here i'm going to
give you dark sister like no
dude do not get close to the guy no
nobody's giving up valerian steal no
okay
especially not to some diseased goon
yeah
he's never giving it up uh that's a very
important sword uh
to the targaryens um but did you like
this plan do you think it was a good way
to in the in the war i think i did like
it both it made for a beautiful action
set piece but also it it was a great
character developer for damon's
character right like a he's been labeled
the most dangerous man in the realm
right we've heard people say that but
that danger is kind of implied to be
like because he makes bad decisions and
he's a little kooky or whatever right
but now we see like you know he's also
like the most dangerous in that like he
wins battles right we also that this is
the first time really in this whole
season we've seen somebody out there
chopping heads right like just doing
some jon snow
jamie lannister level sword play one man
army kind of stuff
and that was really cool right a lot of
this
battle harkened back to battle of the
bastards right where for very different
reasons jon snow like rushes into battle
by himself that was unplanned and
clearly this was planned i think like
somebody here is a good strategist i
think we're left to assume it's damon
right but like this was clearly a good
strategy now one could argue why did it
take him three years to come up with
this but again i yeah i think it's like
you need to get the triarchy to this
point where they've been winnowed down
they're stuck on this one island because
presumably before they were just kind of
all over the place picking off wherever
they needed to but you got them trapped
you got them cornered you got them to a
point where you can finally finish them
off in in one fell swoop uh i love your
point about like who's the good
strategist here uh it was laenor who
pointed out that like hey we need damon
to do this like he's crazy enough to do
it uh but it also felt that like you
know this was like
viserys says this is corals and damon's
war but it really felt like coralus is
war right everyone at the plotting table
it's all it's all the valerians they're
the ones kind of running this and it
feels like damon probably doesn't care
like we know he doesn't want to he
didn't want to be a part of the hot the
small council he just wanted to run his
little his little city watch uh so i i
don't think he liked going to the
planning meetings no i think he was like
showing up killing off a few pirates and
then but he wants to be king right he
said that out loud he wants to be named
heir and he saw this as a vehicle to
establish that claim right and they
certainly teased that next week uh this
is this is going to give him great
renown
uh and show that he is a powerful yes
king of the narrow sea he says in the
teaser for next episode um we want to
quickly shout out a couple uh folks that
helped us bring this episode to you like
our friends mint mobile when it comes
to ruling there is always a catch maybe
you might have to marry your infant
sibling maybe gross maybe maybe being
the king is actually killing you slowly
infecting your flesh awful uh that same
is true for wireless phone service okay
there's always a catch
there's always a catch but thankfully
mint mobile is out there offering
premium wireless starting at just 15
bucks a month and the best part no catch
no catch mint mobile secret sauce is
that they're the first company to sell
wireless service online only they cut
out the cost of retail stores and pass
those sweet savings directly to you
many folks here at new rockstars have
switched mint mobile
including a few of our editors philip
molina they all really like it they were
able to keep their phones their numbers
their contacts and they just straight up
save a bunch of money they get good
service everything like that they've
loved uh ever since they made the switch
and so for anyone out there who hates
their phone bill mint mobile offers
premium wireless for just 15 bucks a
month mipmobile gives you the best rate
whether you're buying for one or a
family all plans come with unlimited
talk and text plus high speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5g
network use your own phone with any mint
mobile plan and keep your same phone
number switch to mint mobile and get
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks and get
the plan shipped to your door for free
go to mittmobile.com
big q that's mintmobile.com bigq cut
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com
big q thank you to mitt mobile well zach
now that the crab feeder is dead we
don't have to worry about the triarchy
threatening the step stones any longer
but one thing we do still have to worry
about is cybercrime
thankfully avast is a global leader in
cyber protection for more than 30 years
and trusted by over 435 million users
and prevents over 1.5 billion with a b
attacks every month wow a vast all
a vast new all-in-one solution of s1
helps you take control of your safety
and privacy online through a range of
features a vast one is their best
protection yet giving you everything you
need to take control of your safety and
privacy online and accessible through a
single easy to use interface a vast
multitude of features provide you with
privacy and security as you scour the
web and even help with your machine's
performance i personally like their
award-winning antivirus that stops
viruses and malware from harming my
devices as well as their data breach
monitoring that will alert you if your
online accounts have been compromised
that's always great to know because the
companies don't always tell you
they even have pc speed up which
optimizes the background activity of
your apps in order to speed up your pc
thanks to a vast one for supporting big
question confidently take control of
your online world with a vast one it
helps you stay safe from viruses
phishing attacks ransomware hacking
attempts and all other cyber crimes
learn more about avast one at avast.com
again check out a vast one at avast.com
all right we were also wondering right
like it is i don't know that anybody
ever directly says it in the episode but
it is heavily implied by his look that
the crab feeder has greyscale yes and if
you ever watch after the episode they
have like the creators talk about the
show a little bit they did confirm that
it was greyscale yeah it definitely has
grayscale you could see it on the side
of his face if you remember from game of
thrones this is like uh uh something
that uh uh what's his face is just
dennis baratheon has it has it uh uh
it's it's a disease uh there's like
famously the stone men of valeria right
that all have it and it's basically like
a kind of a leprosy right yes but it's
transferred by touch and blood uh and
you know damon targaryen was clearly
covered in the crabmeater's blood
chopped him in half maybe he didn't know
about the grayscale
i don't know but do you think he's at
risk of getting grayscale now because
this was something that was different
from the books it's not it's not said in
the books that the crab theater had
grayscale so this is kind of a new
element they've added in uh again the
books are especially fire and blood it's
kind of like an unreliable narrator
a lot of times you get a roshaman style
like account of what happened from
different perspectives and little little
details are different this show you know
it's done with george rr martin uh and
it's kind of filling in the holes and
saying like yes this did happen and it
fits with the book so do you think this
grayscale thing is gonna come up at all
i say no and here's why i think they
gave him grayscale because in universe
grayscale is a great way to make a
character very ugly yeah right it is a
deforming nasty skin disease right
and they wanted it for the contrast
between damon and the crab feeder damon
is a handsome gentleman right matt smith
got that jawline that silky white hair
that nice porcelain complexion the crab
feeder no hair just a couple nasty wisps
coming out the back of that heartbeat
helmet issues maybe yes there's some
weird eye stuff going on obviously his
skin is raggedy and i think they wanted
to contrast that because by the end
guess who's looking a little bit more
like the crab feeder oh
damon right he has to get down and dirty
to defeat this enemy and i think that
was the metaphor they were looking for
right beauty has to he literally has to
come off his high horse the horse in
this case being a dragon in order to
defeat this nasty grubby crustacean
level uh enemy right i think that's what
they wanted out of the grayscale more so
than like the threat of uh contagion
yeah we also have to remember that the
targaryens have
powers in a weird way uh
most notably like their resistance to
heat and fire you know obviously uh uh
uh in game of thrones um daenerys
sits in a fire and like is unburnt she's
the one multiple times i've ever heard
of it uh but also in the very first
episode if you remember viserys when he
was down in the catacombs and looking at
valerian's skull the skull that dragon
he was holding his hand over the flames
if you remember that kind of being like
i am a targaryen i'm resistant to fire
like that's my thing uh so i think that
whatever this weird kind of resistance
the targaryens have to fire and some
diseases i think it's gonna keep it it's
also heavily implied in game of thrones
that uh dragon scale comes from valeria
right like that's where the stone man
are right like there's some connection
possibly to dragons right so maybe as
also descendants of valeria the
targaryens have some kind of built-in
immunity right maybe and it would make
sense if the crab feeder would catch it
because he's sailing around maybe he was
sailing around valeria looking for
artifacts maybe that's where he got his
little harpy mask oh yeah yeah good part
my theory is that that's flotsam and
jetsam those are things that wash up on
shore right he's a man of the beach he's
just picking up random items my thoughts
i mean the crab feeder definitely at his
house has like one of those driftwood
coffee tables yes for sure yeah he's got
like the buoys just
as decoration
like it's a joe's crab shack location
is he like stapling gold coins to the
wall yeah maybe like yeah dollar you can
sign your name on a dollar bill and put
that up on the crab shack's cave yeah
i'm gonna miss the crab feeder uh
another question i had uh about this
episode what do we make of rhaenyra and
damon's respective baptisms by blood you
know we've kind of mentioned this what
do we think like they're really trying
to show us here i i think i kind of sold
it out earlier right this is both of
these characters this is their claim to
the throne right hey i've i've done some
stuff i'm a person of action the current
king not a person of action right he
needs that he needs that buck held down
for him and even then he can't deliver
the killing blow both over get the gods
are punishing him for his indulgence he
can't he can't deliver that killing blow
both of these characters can and do
yeah
uh uh rainer delivers several killings
killing blows we can only assume crab
feeder got taken out in one wow that's a
great kind of moment too as she's
walking back into the camp covered in
this blood a few of the men like look
over and they give her the old like hey
good job yeah wait a way to get dirty or
maybe it's even a little bit like you've
never been hotter to me
oh you know what i mean i love a little
boar's blood on my ladies you know what
i'm talking about yeah uh yeah i i think
you're right zach that this is them both
showing like i deserve it i've earned it
i've gone through my my bloody ordeal
and maybe even convincing themselves a
little bit right not just the other
people around but like yeah i now
believe i can do it i've overcome this
seemingly insurmountable thing and like
now i'm ready yeah okay well zach this
is talking dragons which is a fantasy
after show so let's talk about the other
big fantasy show on the docket right now
let's do a little talking talking yes
we're doing little rings of power let's
talk a little bit about rings of power
now real quick uh we're not going to be
able to go into a ton of depth right
they dropped two episodes on us three
hours of content is too much for us to
get into at about 45 minutes or an hour
of this content but we are just going to
do kind of a quick run through of some
things we like some things we're looking
forward to on rings of power i wanted to
say real quick before you get into a
plot synopsis i think one cool thing and
what a nice time it is to be alive for
fans of fantasy right in that it would
be easy to lump these two shows together
because they're coming out at about the
same time big expensive productions
right but i love that there are also
some significant differences between
these two shows they are approaching
their content in very different ways
they're giving us different stuff i
think it's really cool i don't think you
have to be a fan of one or the other for
me i'm enjoying different shows i'm
enjoying both for completely different
reasons right i i thought of this
metaphor you let me know if this works
for you it's a little bit like
a john wayne western versus a clint
eastwood western okay i think the rings
of power is the john wayne that is the
archetype that is good versus evil it is
like pretty clearly defined yeah white
hat black hat game of thrones is the
anti-western that's that's clint
eastwood that's pale writer outlaw josie
wales high plains drifter right that is
taking the archetype that was
established by tolkien in the 40s or
whatever right and breaking it apart go
swerving right breaking your
expectations and so i think it's cool
you can enjoy both of those things i
think that's what we're getting right
now so let's give a little quick
synopsis of what's going on in rings of
power we're in the second h of middle
earth the elves have driven the evil
forces of molgoth away and they think
they've gotten rid of sauron but
galadriel knows otherwise the elves have
built quite an infrastructure on
middle-earth they've got buildings
everywhere towers police forces but it
seems like neither the men nor the
dwarves want them there everyone wants a
mound get out of here yeah knife ears
and running around beneath all of them
are the harfoots including nori
brandyfoot who has found a big man who
fell from the sky big saying a man
they call him a giant uh he could be
bigger than a normal man we haven't had
a normal man near there's some
wizard-like properties he's got a beard
i don't know i don't know um there are
some mystical artifacts that are making
their ways into different characters
possessions including a very uh pulp
fiction-esque what's in the briefcase
moment with the dwarves magical sword
hilt uh maybe uh and and beneath all of
this the orcs are tunneling around
stealing people from their homes
which i think is adorable uh it's all
setting the stage for another middle
earth shattering battle uh so you had
this idea zach and i really like this
let's do a quick either or between the
two shows uh through their opening
episodes where we're at right now and
and these are just like a couple
categories because again i like that
these shows are approaching different
shows very different right like um the
more magical show well that's clearly
rings of power yeah rings got the magic
right now game of thrones and this you
know all of the game of thrones
franchise other than the occasional
zombie mountain or something like that
you know a little wildfire here or there
it's it's just dragons or the magic
right maybe a smoke monster uh whatever
but like for the most part game of
thrones is set in a
realistic universe well and yeah game of
thrones you know the magic in game of
thrones work some of the time doesn't
work other moments of time yeah it's
more of like we'll try this out yeah
we'll see if this works whereas in in
rings of power right we're getting
there's proof of concept yes we're
getting crazy elf uh fight sequences
where they're dancing on the ends of
blades right a guy from the sky who's
talking to fireflies yeah there's some
real magic going there's some real magic
uh now on the other end sexier show oh
okay okay now this is this is open to
interpretation this is definitely open
to interpretation so far only one has
given us nudity right
though though the man from the sky the
stranger was almost nude yeah he had a
cod piece there was there was a
loincloth of some of some kind uh but
we've seen
i believe two damon targaryen cheeks
we've seen both cheeks targaryen
twice as many cheeks as rings of power
have given us a lot of the nudity on
game of thrones or house of the dragon
involves what we will call pillow houses
which i think is the cutest term to give
the uh the concept of uh uh a brothel
human trafficking yes uh so i don't know
how sexy that is to some people yeah and
i will say like though damon did take
one of the women with him he took uh his
lady to dragons
and pretended to say he was going to
marry her there's been literal sex on
house of the dragon no actual sex though
though there was a little i did love the
har foots looking down on the stranger
in his crater and being like hubba hubba
there was definitely a lot of
action there there's also maybe some
implied stuff going on yes
between bronwyn and aaron dear right
like
definitely some smoldering elf on human
action there
is is theo her son yes he does look a
little oh a little like aaron dear i
don't know i i kind of like well and
there's a there's a little there's a
missing dad missing right
which is a little chekhov's missing dad
right that's going to be important
somehow especially it looks like theo is
going to play a really big part going on
i do love too how like the elves are all
like sexy yes they're all beautiful and
like that's one of their things where
it's like if you're pretty you're an elf
yeah basically yeah no suspicious much
like targaryens no bald elfs now no no
acne scarred elves they get to live
forever with all their hair though damn
the humans of the southland
ragged rough wife rough life down there
no besides besides homegirl bronwyn yeah
not a lot of attractive humans on this
show okay it's a lot of dudes uh
chopping their heads off of fish with
frickin mangled old uh faces and gray
hairs what are you doing talking to the
knife ears what's so good about them i
don't know maybe they take a bath geez
southplan get it together um oh now this
is a this is a good one better food show
now this was a very food forward
house of the dragon episode we got some
shots of the big feast yeah though they
weren't always shown in the most
appetizing light we cut directly from
crab feeder to a giant you know uh spit
roasted pig or something like that uh
not super appetizing and we mostly get
you know king uh slam and wine there uh
as opposed to rings of power boy those
har flits love them some berries don't
the berries look good in the little
escargot the raw snails i don't know
about so much now i love a s card go
cook my snail please oh also we get
black milk coming out of uh
that was disturbing maybe neither show
right now is really winning in the
better food show now here's a category i
think i i think classic dragons is
winning and better okay so far so far
okay i i think wings of power is going
to snap certainly the sommelier on house
of the dragon is doing some work we're
getting right uh honey monster was able
to like snap his fingers to get some
wine it was great they had pigs in a
rotating spit this is this is technology
at work now this is probably a question
we we should say jessica knows a lot
more about this topic than either of us
but better wigs okay now i will say
both shows leaning heavily on wigs all
those targaryens are wearing fancy white
wigs almost every character it seems
like in
except for the elves and that's been
controversial online a lot of people
pissed that some of the elves have short
hair
whatever what are you going to do uh hey
long hairs can be impractical i mean you
can get mad about it but just remember
it's all made up it's all made up now
that's right that's right if you're
getting mad
you're the fool
there's a great you're the mum or spice
if you're getting mad at it there's a
great phrase in uh improv comedy where
if you're the only one in the room not
having fun you're the [ __ ] so i would
just say if you hate one of these shows
quit watching it watch the other show
exactly
that's what i'm saying you don't have to
consume all content okay you don't have
to love it it's not made for you okay
sorry so what i'll say is better i think
the wigs on house of the dragon are
better okay with the asterisk that the
beard worked on those dwarves those
dwarfs was so good the braided beard
tucked in rich i love that the helmets
got a beard guard yes the beard work
really saved the episode that dwarf
sequence i mean yeah great beard work
great costuming on this series same
customer that worked on the jackson
films though as as behind the scenes
daschle pointed out we want full beards
on those dwarf ladies
the princess there the dwarven princess
just kind of had some like full action
going on
full beard give the ladies
and then finally right it it so far
both these series seem to have
interesting themes kind of as they
relate to modern society even though
neither of these series are set on earth
in a world that we recognize right they
of course reflect back the world we know
in 2022. how's the dragon very upfront
about
right
investigating tackling whatever misogyny
right like this kingdom doesn't want to
see a woman on the throne what's it like
for a woman in this world versus a man
yada yada whereas rings of power is
playing with a lot in all of tolkien's
work is playing with race a lot now this
is specifically like
different races of creatures like
species species right elves versus
dwarves versus men versus orcs whatever
but like you can't help but see the
metaphor there right and certainly with
uh uh
aaron dear is played by a non-white
person right which even makes it more in
contrast when there's a non-white elf
interacting uh with humans right um and
i think like
which of those for you
is kind of tackling that theme or or
investigating that like more effectively
so far i i really think uh i like house
of the dragons but they're kind of
taking it
what they're kind of showing us with the
idea of like the patriarchy and what's
gonna change i also love the idea that
you know you have these the men of
science like the maesters right they're
still just trying to figure things out
yeah like everything's changing and
always evolving but it it does feel like
a lot of what we've already heard on
game of thrones game of thrones where
which which almost is a great mirror and
that like in the 200 years not much is
going to change
in westeros
much like uh you know in our world like
the middle ages not much changed from
the beginning to the end of the middle
ages right it took getting to
enlightenment to really push us forward
and get us there i mean we not to step
on our power rankings we're just coming
next we know some things are changing
those valerians
not looking good for you in the next
couple of years my dudes there's not a
lot of you in game of thrones that's all
i got to say yeah look out guys yeah uh
but i do like what rings of power is
kind of showing the idea of you know
if you let these divisions of of species
or race divide you you're missing the
bigger problem right if you're so
focused on on these things like that's
what i don't understand with all these
people who want the elves to leave it's
like the elves came in and cleaned up
shop they they fig they they drove out
the evil you guys should be happy that
they're here trying to keep the people i
think but our differences naturally
separate us and that's why it's a bigger
deal when there's a fellowship yeah
right when the species have to come
together it means more
if we're not chilling hanging out no one
trusts each other like the dwarves don't
trust the elves the elves don't trust
anybody that people don't trust the
elves it's it's all about mistrust uh
and they're gonna let this evil kind of
grow right beneath them uh literally
right beneath them because they're too
busy fighting each other yep
uh so let's do it let's do our power
rankings do we want to do them for both
shows you you want to uh yeah real quick
real quick i'll say big winners obvious
who's up this week in our power rankings
obviously damon targaryen big win for
damon big win for damon gets that kill
our first baddie of the series is dunzo
we were speculating do they need a new
outside threat right because like this
show is so insular it's these same like
characters in court kind of like
backstabbing each other maybe we need
some more outside threats to worry about
who knows i like that um but damon big
win for damon i think a big win for
rhaenyra this week yeah she's she kind
of showed everyone all the bannermen
right were at this like hunt i think her
kind of showing back up covered in blood
got a big bore just on my own just with
my buddy kristen cole here uh i think
that was a big win for her definitely i
also think uh corliss valerian is way up
this week on the back of damon yeah his
his little like wager
him walking away as master of ships and
joining forces with damon i think it
paid off well for him and by proxy his
son right lanor kind of making his first
appearance on the power charts this week
and certainly that only benefits his
father right when his son is a bigger
player and he's doing some dragging
around
yeah now who's down just just let's keep
it with house of the dragon he's down on
house i mean crab feeder
what body parts going to be gone next
episode on viserys i want to see him
lose like a nose or something like just
like something he can't hide anymore
because right now he can hide everything
i think the next thing he loses is going
to be harder to hide yeah harder to hide
a point maybe he's maybe he's like
a year goes away yeah maybe he's like
chair-bound bed-bound at some point
right not looking good for him and his
degradation there also when he when when
him and allison are
getting
busy carnal yeah uh do you think she's
like don't touch me with the
keep the gloves
yeah uh don't ever show your back to me
that must be the state of his background
his back must be looking awful uh his
back must be looking awful i'll also say
uh the lannisters went down a notch this
would be good it showed up and
immediately dropped down didn't look
good not a good look for the lannisters
the nouveau reef a secret might be on
the up and up the strongs okay we got
bad foot strong there yeah right the one
son uh who's showing up just eating his
cookie listening there's something going
on there while their sons were there
like uh yes one of his sons is bone
breaker yes he's got an awesome name
yeah yeah uh yeah the strong's slowly
getting in there they're working
you know the high towers are always
rising too they're they're slowly
working their way back up yep uh all
right let's talk about rings of power
who who do you think gain the most power
and wings of power
i mean just by proxy to
the big uh wizard macguffin of the
series those heart foots
oh poppy and nori they've got a secret
weapon you know these were like
literally woodland creatures up until
this point who hid from everybody else
yeah zero interaction with the outright
creatures yeah no interaction with the
outside world and now who might be like
the hugest game changer on the series is
interlinked with the hard foot so i
think they're a big gainer
uh i would say like the dwarves are
really up this week uh they you know
they have this secret macguffin uh and i
think it showed they have a lot of power
and also you know uh uh they show up
they'll show up and they're like oh
you've done a lot in like 20 years yeah
they're clearly on the rise big time yes
uh and i think i think they really
showed that they're up they got an upper
hand real quick we forgot to mention
this earlier do you think elrond legit
lost that rock breaking
contest or did he do it to help the
prince save fish i think i think he did
to help the princess face i think he was
ready to keep going and he was like this
this tactic's not going to work for me i
i can't beat him and then beyond his
good graces i've got to like lose
i gotta lay it down yes uh gotta help
his buddy durian save somebody
yeah who's who's down this week in the
rings of power power rankings humans
humans are waves humans are doing awful
uh it's kind of a recurring theme in
tolkien's work they're the least likable
characters often the most the most
susceptible to corruption by evil right
right also i don't trust
that um that gym maker what's his he's
got that great selling brim yes i mean
he's a little too obsessed with making
something of beauty and even drops his
line to make something great needs
sacrifice but you sacrifice someone yeah
also like you got to get this thing done
by the spring you couldn't have planned
better not a good planner no not a good
planner i don't i mean i know he's
destined for some important stuff in the
series but i'm worried yeah i am worried
too uh but i can't wait to find out more
on both of these shows that's it for
this episode of big question presents
talking dragons be sure to check us out
each and every week here on new rock
stars spitting fire with these
targaryens and sharing snails with the
heart foots each and every week don't
forget to check out our many great merch
options at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at grinnenberg follow zack at
z huddleston don't follow me do it
it's not
you should follow new rockstars at new
rockstars on twitter and instagram uh
subscribe to bigquestion wherever you
watch uh or listen to podcasts and don't
forget to check out
newrockstarsmerch.com
where you can get the latest obsession
uh game of thrones uh um shirt and
upcoming andor shirts there's also some
great she-hulk merch options on there
and some rings of power rings of power
merch i think maybe uh
newrockstarsmerch.com thank you for
watching jessica will be back next week
also keep an eye out if you're watching
this uh right when it drops eric's
breakdown of the stuff of the episode oh
yes uh house of the dragon will be
coming out soon and he's doing a
breakdown of the first two episodes of
rings of power so keep an eye out for
them keep an eye out for those yes keep
an eye out for those and remember i'm
sick of all this politicking goodbye
[Music]
you